[Music]
american officials have turned stadiums
fairgrounds and even
disneyland into mega vaccination sites
trying to gain the upper hand on the
coronavirus
and other countries are also finding
creative places to vaccinate as many
people as possible
our roxanna berry is at one of those
sites in london
roxanna good morning to you
good morning tony the uk has now
vaccinated more than 6 million people
that gives it the third highest per
capita vaccination rate among major
countries
after israel and the uae people here can
now get vaccinated at super sites like
this town hall
and at other unexpected places
for eight centuries the cathedral in
salisbury england has soared over the
faithful
go up now to the left-hand side to go
now it's hosting the hopeful
potatoes isn't it welcome like
85-year-old daphne morat
she recently joined more than 1 000
others here getting vaccinated against
covet 19
in a single day
[Music]
when people enter they register and get
seated at one of these booths
because this cathedral is so spacious 12
people can be vaccinated
at the same time they're then monitored
for adverse reactions
how was the vaccination today it didn't
feel a thing
except it's cold you know if when you're
waiting that's the only thing i could
say
as they wait at safe social distances
they relax to bark and handle
don't forget they haven't heard live
music
for months it is an unusual place to
treat patients
right but dr mchale georgie says it's
ideal for administering
large numbers of the pfizer vaccine
which spoils fast at room temperature
it allows us to adapt the space for what
we need in terms of vaccination
observation areas and exits it's a
central location
everyone knows where it is it's not hard
to find across the uk
other sites shut down by the lockdown
have transformed into venues for mass
vaccinations with people lining up
at horse racing tracks a rugby stadium
and this cinema
pity films not put on officials say
almost a tenth of the population has
already received the first dose of a
covid19 vaccine
other countries are also setting up
makeshift mega sites in
unconventional locations like this food
court in moscow
this museum in beijing and beside this
iconic statue
in rio de janeiro israel which leads the
world in per capita vaccinations
now injects up to 7 000 people a day in
this historic square
not only is it a communal feeling and
they may see their neighbors here
but also there's just a feeling of
celebration but in the european union
vaccinations at hubs like this ice rink
in berlin
have stalled following a shortage of
vaccines in the uk
too officials are expecting delays and
deliveries this week
threatening plans to give around 15
million people a dose by the middle of
next month
is it going fast enough it's never going
fast enough as for those who've already
rolled up their sleeves they hope this
is a move toward
more freedom and i'll see my sonoma
daughter again
and that will be nice
[Music]
despite its progress this country is
still grappling with a more contagious
variant of the virus
so officials here are considering
tougher measures like tighter border
controls and keeping schools closed
until easter gail thank you roxanna
there would be something comforting to
me to go into a cathedral in canada i'm
looking at that that's i want to go to
salisbury cathedral to get my
vaccinations good juju if you get it
gorgeous yeah yeah and live music
serenaded with organ music love it the
lady who said she could see her daughter
again i know
that little accent there at the end yeah
i like that